I think Ramsay Bolton was the worst
character it yep it's a babe what is
what is he one round like in real life
he's just like the empty bones yeah no
he's the sweetest it's so funny how the
most that like the most evil characters
on the show are actually the sweetest
people there's a new play Joffrey was
the nicest person in the world and you
one who plays Ramsay so sweet and he's
so hard-working and I'm really gonna
miss him so this is a great girl you
know really a really great time working
with her it's so mature and the way she
dealt with her son particularly some of
the storylines and into scenes you know
she was great you know be a bishop we
should have a lot of fun she's a real
gigglers oh yeah she can giggle and then
switch it off I can't do that so she
makes me laugh and then she just turns
into Sansa and I'm just a oh come on you
can't do that to me just for sake what
is it like for you when you walk down
first Street okay you feel nice yeah
yeah I think generally people you know
the girls they find it comical so they
kinda oh you're you're horrible you are
but they know I think I mean maybe a lot
of people don't come and talk to me
because this case but I think I wouldn't
know but I think generally people they
know of and I said yeah they're not
intimidated by me that's good I've heard
I've heard stories of people being like
oh people want to punch me in the face
yeah a lot of people have said that yeah
yeah I've never really played a villain
before to be honest so it's kind of the
first time I've ever had a proper popery
so yeah it's been really fun play a nice
nice character next I think